for the first time in eight years the
Stanley Cup final requires a
winner-take-all game seven last time
this happened I believe the Bruins and
Vancouver I was in Vancouver for that
and that wasn't pretty after Vancouver
lost and just getting out of town what's
the movie with bad Ben Affleck in one
word you know where they escape it's
about the Iran hostage crisis Argo
that's what it felt like we were leaving
Vancouver in Vancouver's a lovely place
and great people and there's fires in
the street and there's social unrest and
I'm like wait a minute this was just a
hockey game doc Emmerich joins us doc
has seen it all as the NHL and NBC
play-by-play voice doc how are you today
I'm good but that was unforgettable did
you notice in your rear view mirror yes
I was setting over Vancouver and there
were there was smoke rising in the
background it was and was one of the
all-time weird memories and it was the
only time that that ever seemed to
happen in any of the cities we ever
visited and you would think Vancouver
like you know I know that they loved
their hockey but this was Vancouver and
we're trying to get out of the I'm with
Mike Milbury and I feel pretty safe with
Millbury we're just trying to get to the
airport there after that game are you
picked Millberry to be with yes man who
went up with a shoe and it is yeah you
are I think in terms of protection you
probably did make a good choice have you
ever brought up that incident with Mike
Milbury
when he went into the stands with a shoe
to rough up a fan he's sort of smiles
and shakes his head and and doesn't
really talk too much about it you take
your cue from him
yeah I'm curious about the etiquette we
I was talking about the US Women's World
Cup team they scored 13 goals against
Highland and you know there's the
tiebreaker with goal differential and I
understand that it's just after a
certain point where you go okay you're
still scoring you don't need to
celebrate like this is the only goal of
the game is there certain sportsmen
in the NHL in a game that do you keep
piling on or do you see teams that let
up when they're blowing out somebody's
7-nothing Eddie Olczyk pointed out late
in Game six that st. Louis was starting
to do some rough stuff and that is a
sort of an archaic philosophy that was
established by the roughhouse teams of
the 70s and I'm not saying that it
reared its ugly head but there were a
couple of rough incidents that resulted
in power plays and Eddie brought up that
it was a decisive lead for Boston then
and if you really wanted to send a
message home that we don't appreciate
this you would have sent out Bergeron
posture knock and Marshawn for the last
power play to say okay hmm do you want
to do this we're gonna run up the score
so there's still are occasions where
this happens but we do have it
particularly in women's hockey in the
Olympics where there are some mismatches
and because of gold differential you
will see teams you know wind up winning
games by double digits but it it sure as
a viewer it doesn't make for the best
competition and and as a broadcaster it
does make you uncomfortable at times
because you hate to see one team totally
disheartened like that but that's at
least the view from hockey soccer I'm
not terribly familiar with but you
really you don't like to see mismatches
but but they do happen in international
competitions and we've had the u.s. and
Canada have been you know the decided
favorites and all of these women's
competitions with Sweden and Finland
being very competitive but some of the
other nations just haven't caught up
blues Bruins game 7 tonight at 8:00
Eastern on NBC pregame coverage starts
at 6:00 Eastern on NBCSN with NHL live
doc is calling his 45th game 7 all-time
5th game 7 in the Stanley Cup final is
there a different game plan for a game 7
as the broadcaster there is and Sam
flood our executive producer of sports
always emphasizes that we get a lot more
people to watch a game 7 that may not be
hockey fans they're fans of events that
have great magnitude like a game 7 in
any sport and so we want to broaden the
strokes a little bit in terms of how we
paint a game 7 want to make sure that we
don't leave people that are joining and
wanting to watch hockey for maybe a
first time in a in a few months or maybe
the first time this year and not leave
them behind we want to background them
on the two teams without going into a
lot of X's and O's we want to give them
a background on what the series has been
like so far and the athletes that are
playing it so there there is a little
different approach to that and it's
similar to winter classics and games
that are outdoors then to attract more
people in New Year's Day so yes there's
a different approach for Game seven I
always find gold gold tenders
fascinating and I don't know if there's
but doc I don't know if anybody's ever
done a study on just their mental makeup
if you had a lot of these legendary gold
tenders just sit down and and you just
analyzed who they are what they are what
they think because they're different you
have to be different to want to do that
for a living
has anybody ever done a study on gold
tenders and they're their brains and
what they you know why you want to do it
what you think when you're in goal the
fact that a goaltender can change an
entire series can help you win a Stanley
Cup single-handedly there's a very
well-spoken goaltender that might be fun
for you to have on sometimes a Bryant
with Shay was been a part of our
telecast this year and he has been able
to put that into words several times
during these playoffs when we've asked
him about it it is uh it is a mentality
that you get oftentimes at 7 or 8 years
of age in the early years of playing you
wind up playing all positions and
they're just some guys that gravitate
toward it and decide that they like it I
found that at one time in my years of
doing this is 46 now in the early years
they tend to be viewed as
non-conventional and flaky there were
gold tenders that were not very good
skaters and so they wound up being given
the position assigned the position and
handed the equipment but now they are
there
best coached and they are the most
schooled and as they are little kids
they they go to summer camps that are
exclusively adult ending camps and they
are as I said the best coach they are
often the most introspective and because
they are by themselves a lot and so they
do tend to be more quiet it's it's hard
to paint them with with the same brush
as you do the other players and to
generalize on them but they tend to be
quieter and they tend to be probably
more introspective and more careful when
they choose their words than other
players they aren't able to when when a
goal score celebrates a goal everybody
gathers around them what a goaltender
makes this day somebody will come by and
it happens but his celebration has to be
more internal than anything else but we
have two wonderful goal tenders and
Tooker asked if the Bruins win is
probably going to be the MVP an MVP can
be the member of the losing team and if
Boston wins there may be a question
about whether Ryan O'Reily might be the
pecans mites Trophy winner for MVP but
to carascas is going in tonight with the
number one record and goals against and
save percentage and all of that because
he has really been the backbone of this
round Florida have we seen the evolution
of the goalie where I know that you
could have somebody like Darren pang who
was 5 4 and then you could have Patrick
wah Ben bishop could you see where you
could have somebody the size not like
Shaquille O'Neal but somebody who is 6 9
and 300 pounds
who's playing goalie
well there's that one there's that
walrus in the geico come to that but at
one time when Ken Dryden was playing and
winning for the Montreal Canadiens 1971
the speculation was that's as tall as a
goaltender is ever going to get because
there's never going to be any kind of
coordination for anyone that size to be
able to do the maneuvering this
necessary and goal but the equipment was
much smaller than and now it is much
larger and goaltender's as I said of the
most coached and they're there they're
in camps all the time and there's a
goalie coach for all the teams that
works with these guys constantly and so
now we had four goal tenders that were
under six feet the rest were all larger
you mentioned Ben Bishop but what six
eight yeah Devin since eight I don't
know that there's a limit but there is
probably when you're getting up around
300 pounds you're not going to have
defensive linemen from the NFL
converting the goaltender's it's just
not going to happen the goal scorers are
too good then that's still four by six
and you know you might you might have an
idea about getting a walrus sized
goaltender in there but he's still got
to move doc have fun tonight it it's my
favorite event in all the sports when
you have a Game seven
with the Stanley Cup in the building and
should be a lot of fun there in Boston
Thank You doc thank you my favorite -
thanks doc Emmerich
he's called 45 this would be his 45th
game 7 all-time 5th game 7 in the
Stanley Cup final tonight there's a
reason why he's won six sports Emmys you
just listen to that voice tonight and I
say this every single year at this time
just listen to the voice whether you
understand the game have a vested
interest in it it is entertaining and
he's he's special for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]